well
[Music]
firefighters fought against strong flames
in a shopping center in the valley how
are you greeted by cristian cásseres with his
new news now in Spanish
I tell you that the incident occurred
early Monday morning in the plaza rodeo
on price and flamingo according to
Clark County Investigators at
least 50 firefighters responded and
worked to put out the two-
alarm fire that destroyed several businesses and
I tell you that
the death of a UVI student
who died in a boxing fight organized
by a fraternity on Saturday remains under investigation  Just the
day he would have turned 21,
a vigil was held for Nate in
Valencia, who died after suffering severe
injuries to his brain during a
charity boxing match. His girlfriend
told the media that there were no
medical professionals present. The Valencia family
has hired  a lawyer and ask
for accountability
three people died in a crash
near program el  Sunday
morning the mishap occurred near
state route 373 in amargos abel and
state police say it was the
recklessness of a driver that caused the
triggering that claimed the lives of
three of the five passengers traveling
inside a minivan on  driver was
arrested and is facing DUI charges
and officers of the day would like to
remind you that Monday
is traditionally the busiest day for the
department so the public is asked
to opt to take advantage
of online services instead of going to the
offices  in person you are also
reminded that there is a god that
in supermarkets throughout the valley to which you
can go to see where they are
located visit the page of the day send
directly
and the baseball field the bold scholarships
so that you have hit a home run for your
christmas experience in sant which
opened this weekend as you can
see on your screen the experience
offers a forest of tall
illuminated trees a  he enchantée
ice skating rink and much more
is located ensamble in and
will remain open through january 2nd and we
close taking a look at the
temperatures we start the week with a
sunny day the temperatures will be in
the low seventies but we will have
temperatures more  higher than normal to
start the month of December I am Cristian
Cásseres with super informative news
now in Spanish good day